webin hours now streaming live on custom
live Ste Dem service okay I still I
still need to do some things it it it
minute it says
live well that's good when my phone rang
we don't have any recording that my
phone rang while we were doing a
it's getting the money it's GNA be the
hard part I know
that all right apparently the The Voice
didn't um appear but we are all set now
thank you okay it says recording up at
the top Corner okay uh so as chair of
the house Commerce consumer affairs
committee I find this that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covid-19
panic in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a committee
orientation meeting please note there is
no physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen uh
contemporarily to this meeting however
in accordance with the emergency order I
am confirming that uh all the members of
the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
cont temporarly during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access I'm
not going to make me say it again
contemporar asly listen and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court web
system two the notice for this meeting
uh notice complies with all house rules
in RSA 91a three anyone who has a
problem accessing the meeting should
call
271-3600 or email
HCS ledge. state. n.
us finally in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled I want
to introduce Pam smling our house
committee researcher who is assisting us
with this meeting please note that all
the votes that are taken during this
meeting oh we we're not taking any votes
and let's start the meeting by taking a
ro no we won't bother with a roll call
what do you think P should we do a roll
call I think it's a good idea actually
this is a this is a meeting although
you're not voting or acting on anything
and it's it's good practice so uh Keith
Keith you're muted at the moment um do
you do you have the list of all the
committee
members I do not I am uh new to the to
the clerk position so any any guidance
you can give me can help me okay all
right then I'll then I'll sent it by
email um
I don't know if
you're I'll look for it right now
okay but one I'll just I'll I'll just go
ahead okay so uh I see the email it's uh
from 9:46 this morning yes all right you
want me to call roll call the roll so
all you do is everyone say you say say
you're here and tell us whether there's
anybody in the room with
you go ahead Kate okay I'll just go down
the list here
uh representative John Hunt here and no
one's in the
room representative John pesic puchek
puchek yeah Keith pusk or puchek
whichever uh you however you prefer p
p okay po
sick okay I am present in my back room
which has a bunch of computers in it and
my wife is in the house in the the room
hey John just want to know if there's
anybody in the
room and today's my
birthday happy
birthday happy birthday all right uh
Jason
Osborne okay he might he might join
later uh Keith Ammon that's me here no
and still muted M Max looks like he's
present he he has a
he okay yeah just move on and we'll come
back someone named Max is present yes
welome Back Bonnie ham representative
Bonnie
ham she has a conflicting meeting this
morning L
okay representative Joseph dama
I'm here and I am by
myself here and
alone representative Jeffrey
grion present and I'm by
myself representative Don
Johnson I'm here and I have two noisy
dogs that you may see me get up and put
out on
[Laughter]
occasion all right representative Paul
Terry I'm here and I'm alone
sad representative Christy Bartlett I am
here alone in this
a representative Chris
Herbert I'm here with all my close
friends
nobody here but
me uh representative Connie van
hooton hton you know that together
anyway that's okay I'm here I'm in my
home just to let you know if I Fade to
Black at times I have a puppy here who
believes that eating my furniture is the
most important thing to do so I will
always keep you on but I may have to
black out for a minute so you don't see
okay all right representative Tina Fargo
hi I'm here and my home and I'm
alone
hear can you hear me Max Abramson is
that you yes Max are you are you are you
of okay next all right uh representative
Joyce
Weston I'm here and I'm
alone okay representative Jane
bellu
poo bolo yes
yes but I don't see yeah I don't see her
yet okay bolo all right representative
Anita burough I'm here my husband is in
the house and may walk through here and
I'm sure one of my cats will be making
an appearance during this orientation
all right if it's on the keyboard we'll
try to understand what he's
typing representative Chris MC alier
mcclear mcclear he's on he's on the call
as a particip as a as a part U somebody
listening in not in this part
right as an attendee as an attendee I'm
sorry about I didn't okay so he's
present he is yeah so how do we how do
we upgrade him I just did it um and I
see representative ham has joined us
represent Ham's here hi
Bonnie to un there's mclear okay hi
there I'm here I had a a zoom meeting
that ended at uh 10:12 not 10 so I'm
here and I'm alone
okay okay and then represent
mle I'm
here let me get my video
on there you go are all right I've been
in I've been trying to wave my hand but
obviously nobody's seen
me so I'm I'm here with my dog and two
cats and I do have two workmen um
working in the other room but uh I'll
keep them away from the uh
screen okay
all right
um so um yeah I guess it would normally
tell REM mind everybody to mute your
phones if you're mute your devices
inside your home um and then you are uh
we expect you guys to do your own muting
so we don't if if you're going you're
invited to speak or something like that
I'm I'm I and our Pam are not going to
be turning you on and off in terms of
muting we're relying on you folks to do
your own muting
um okay so now I think we can get
started so hi I'm John Hunt and I've
been on this committee a very long time
uh and um but I'm happy to be here and
excited that we're we're back uh meeting
again um and for another exciting
session um I've as this being my 18th 19
something something like that session I
always say every session is different
and this one is different right out of
the block so we don't have to go far to
get make make this one different
so the I uh what we want to do first is
just go around have everybody kind of
introduce themselves tell us where
you're from anything you know
interesting highlights of who you are
what you've done and uh just so we have
a little feel for everybody so um I live
in ringe uh which is down in the
southwest corner of the state um and I
used to be in the computer retail
business um I am currently uh I live in
a very large house that is often looks
like a castle and um and I do rent it on
home away as a vacation rental
property and uh and welcome you all to
this wonderful committee that is the
best Committee of all originally am from
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania so yes I'm a
Steelers fan and and but Penguins they
they did a lot of penguin advertising
during the football game so so this a
new season so um and so anyway I'm going
to be going around and this is uh you
get a feel for this for those who are
older members they'll know exactly what
I'm talking about but the newer
this is what it would look like when if
we were in our the committee room so to
my right is my vice chairman John pusk
and so John would you unmute yourself
and tell us a little bit about
yourself okay thank you Mr chairman uh
and that is how we normally address uh
John when we're in the committee as Mr
D um uh John pusic I live in Derry I'm
one of the 10 reps uh from Derry is the
largest uh single Town representation in
the State uh Derry happens to be the
fourth largest municipality in the State
uh this is my third term this is my
second term on
Commerce uh my first term uh was a few
years ago and I was a virtually a
permanent substitute in Commerce for
when people were absent uh by the
request of the chair and uh I came
to understand it enjoy it uh I love the
work that we do it's very
complicated it's
difficult uh but it's it's extremely
satisfying um I today's my birthday as I
said I am
74 and yesterday I became a grandfather
for the first time congratulations my
first
grandson uh and his name is John so John
we got a good thing going good name okay
and uh I'm married
for almost 50 years I grew up on the
East Coast I was born in New York City
on Fifth Avenue back in the late
40s uh um I think I might be the oldest
member on the committee
uh if somebody thinks they're older than
me um please let me know I have a few of
my committee members who I know we are
senior
seniors and we're proud of it um I'm on
the dairy Economic Development Committee
okay that's enough that's enough okay
and I I I will cut it out and until we
meet each other in person uh there's a
lot more to do so next okay all right so
Barlett and you can unmute there you go
got it got it yeah I know that's the uh
the phrase of 2020 2020 was you can
unmute yourself um I'm Christy dolite
Bartlett I'm in conquered but John um
Puchi we have 10 representatives in
conquer too um this is my fifth term
I've been on Commerce this is my third
term on Commerce I spent a couple of
terms on environment in
agriculture um I had 35 years in
insurance as an insurance underwriter so
when the insurance bills come up it's
not foreign a foreign language for me um
I'm married and
have two children two stepchildren and
seven grandchildren and I'm a quilter
that's
enough great all right and to uh to her
hi uh Connie van hton my name gets
massacred all the time but I'll work on
it John um I'm coming in into my third
term uh in the legislature which is also
my third term in Commerce my background
however is education I have been a
secondary level teacher I've taught
Middle School I've taught um College ESL
um I've gone the gamut I've learned to
love Commerce it was an acquired taste I
have to say that uh that it was a
learning curve but I'm now very pleased
that I'm going to be back for a third
term and I want to welcome the new
people that are with us and my dog is
barking so I'm
done great so I so I did it wrong I'm
saying it I know how to say this name
but I always do opposite what I should
ham and you there you go uh um I'm
Bonnie ham uh from Lincoln Woodstock
Waterville I was born in Woodstock I'm
in my ninth term here in three different
uh time periods in my life uh the first
time I was uh in the legislature I was
uh Ways and Means and economic
development uh later on I did science
technology and energy and most
recently uh two years ago I was on
criminal
justice I uh have been a guardian and an
on budsman and very involved in the
Health and Human Service field I own two
businesses I'm a landlord and so I
decided when I came back um that uh
Commerce I wanted Commerce to be my
focus because obviously I own two
businesses and am very interested in the
topic it will be a learning curve for me
I have an
MBA uh my first business um I I bought
and owned uh eons ago well nearly 50
years ago and um the second one 27 years
ago and I just Bailey opened a res
restaurant um August 19th right in the
middle of the pandemic so
obviously Commerce um is a topic that I
want to I want to change my focus um to
my my business interests and a bit away
from U my municipal government and
Health and Human Service interests I'm
chair of the planning board I'm on the
school budget committee and as I said uh
I have been elected in um the town of
Woodstock and surrounding towns um since
I was 21 years old I have been uh
fortunate enough to have been uh a to
provide constituent service for the
folks that I I love dearly for um well
quite a while almost almost 50 years so
um I'm very happy to be here this is
where I wanted to
be great
Herbert um Chris Herbert I'm uh this is
going to be my fourth term it'll be my
third term uh on Commerce and I agree
with John the chairman hunt that it's uh
the the probably the best and most
exciting committee we can that that
exists in the house uh my background is
I I actually covered for the Manchester
Union leader when I was a Youngster uh
the legislature with Don tibits I don't
know if anybody knows who Don tibits the
late Don tibit was late Don yeah yeah
and um and then I went and I've done a
bunch of things had my own advertising
agency uh I was a stock broker for Mar
ledge
um I've been on the I was on the school
committee in Manchester for 12 years I
was an alderman for four years and uh
I've been I will now be going into my
seventh and eighth year as a state
representative of which uh I'm very
proud and uh uh I used to be a
Conservative Republican and now the
older I get the more liberal I have
become so I so I am now a Social
Democrat C uh so I mean I actually
worked for Chris sununu's Father John
Hunt John Hunt right John cordan slip
yes right oh jeez uh and so I know the
family pretty well but um I'm glad to be
here and I'm 71 so I'm waiting for my
vaccine I guess and uh hopefully we
won't have to do this all the time
thanks
Weston hi uh yeah I'm Joyce Weston and I
represent um Grafton 8 which is Plymouth
Hein and holderness in the heart of New
Hampshire and I was born and raised in
this state uh in Hollis um but I learned
my trade in New York I'm a graphic
designer uh and was at one point um art
director of National magazine and then
decided to get out of New York and go
freelance so the last 30 years of my
career I designed books and um I have
now stopped doing that just
recently um but uh in in addition I was
also a ski instructor for 37 years and I
gave a lesson to Chris sonunu and his
brother which he probably doesn't
remember but when he was a little kid um
but at any rate this is my second term
my second term on Commerce as well and I
do enjoy the committee as well thank
you I remember I was at his father's
inauguration and I remember Chris when
he was a little
gon yeah good morning Mr chairman good
morning everybody uh I am a rookie in
the legislature and therefore a rookie
on this committee uh I actually did not
put Commerce as one of my choices but I
have no problems with being on it uh
very much uh interested in in small
business and big business uh I I have a
a family background in in business my
family's owned a couple of businesses
it's been a few years since I've
personally owned one uh but I have my
eye on one and and so I'm I'm very much
interested in this committee as well uh
my just as background I'm a transplant
to New Hampshire I retired from the Navy
after 20 years and moved to New
Hampshire in
2014 to Pastor a church here in
Wentworth where I presently live uh I'm
not the the pastor of that particular
church anymore but I am a pastor of a
church in Connecticut right now helping
them to find a new pastor and then uh
might start another another church
somewhere uh somewhere in New England
after that but uh anyway uh looking
forward to what we're going to do this
uh this session that's all I got great
thank you uh representative
Terry you're
on thank you Mr chairman uh I am
uh a u freshman representing Alton and
gilmington um I am a native New
Yorker so it's likely that uh from time
to time you will all of you will hear me
pronounce my RS
that's supposed to be funny yes I got it
uh yes thank you I am a
um ordained Presbyterian Minister
honorably retired after 39 years of
service to congregations in uh New York
Connecticut in Rhode
Island um I as a presbyterian will be
known for as as one who is part of a
tradition who enjoy doing things
decently and in order so I'm sure it'll
be a joy serving on this committee as
well as in the the legislature uh during
my years of service as active Service as
a as a pastor in the Presbyterian
Church I serve three terms as um the
chair of the Board of Trustees for uh my
presbyter 34 churches in three states um
I was president of the corporation I
have a background uh in economics and
and so um I'm very much in my field here
in my element and I'm looking forward to
making a positive contribution as we
move forward lastly I'm married with
um uh one
wife uh three children and five
grandchildren thank
you great uh and I don't see
representative Osborne so moving right
along so going across from him would be
right there you I see you be get there
you I it's uh it's melier it's
pronounced as if it's Mac but so I'm I
live in Jackson um I live in what was a
second home now a permanent home uh this
is my first time I'm uh from Carol
County district 7 which is the floal
position covering uh 10 towns in in um
in Jackson I mean in in New Hampshire uh
my background is in insurance and securi
securities as in Investments not not
policing uh I'm my last place uh that I
lived before moving up here permanently
was was ipswitch mass you probably know
it as the home of the clam uh my claim
to either f or infamy depending on your
Viewpoint uh was I was a classmate of
the soon to be ex president uh that's uh
uh sometimes I'm I'm a little
embarrassed about that but uh at any
rate I'm very happy to be on this
committee I I think it does fit my
background I also uh majored in
economics I also uh at one point work
for for mirl Lynch and uh I don't know
if I recognize Chris Herbert or not but
uh at any rate I'm really happy to be
here a little sideline I'm I'm on the
trustees of trust funds in Jackson and
also on the planning board so this is uh
the The Next Step uh in my uh uh
political career and and probably the
last step for that matter but very happy
to be here and nice to meet all you
people welcome AB aboard uh
next okay uh I'm Anita burough I'm from
um Bartlett I represent also represent
Jackson and Harts location and neighbor
of Chris a fun fact I'm the person who
recruited Chris to run for this office
um uh let's see um I second term I was
on Judiciary last term which I really
enjoyed but I wanted to broaden my
horizons um Ed Butler is a friend and a
mentor so I thought it would be great
for Carol County to have representation
on this committee um my background is in
business I have an MBA spent 20 years in
the high-tech industry and I now uh work
with my husband in a healthcare
Consulting um practice and um let's see
what else I'm originally from New Jersey
though I don't usually uh talk about
that publicly and um I also have a um a
background in managing nonprofits as a
board chair here in um the Mount
Washington Valley and I'm very this was
my first choice and I'm happy to be here
and I just wanted to say to Joseph it
must be very interesting being with
people who are at least 30 years older
than
you
okay um and representative
Johnson representative P do you have a
question yes uh a question for
representative buros two1 or
609 what was that 2011 or 609 oh
2011 thank you I was also Clifton um
Bergenfield and tanl
there you go cool okay now you're on
Johnson represent Johnson hi good
morning so um I represent lonia New
Hampshire um this is my first time
running um so I'm I'm a newbie also
[Laughter]
Jeffrey um commerce was not my first
choice um but I'm excited to be here
after talking to John um and a couple
others I'm I'm excited because I think
this fits um
my my interest more than the others that
I picked I have a degree in accounting
um I actually have my own I do uh
bookkeeping work for many small
businesses so I am in the business um
Community quite a bit and a diff a lot
of
variety and I have been married for 20
almost 21 years I have two children in
high school and I am always on the
go and I have two very noisy dogs one
especially so which is why I keep muting
myself and pulling them off the screen
because I they keep running around on
me great thank you okay uh
representative
dama good morning everyone um I'm Joe
deama I'm from Littleton New Hampshire
and I also
represent um this is my first term so
I'm with you guys
um um I'm 19 years old and I'm a student
at Pou State University um I study
business and sales um and I also work
for my family's storage container rental
business here in Littleton um I look
forward to working with all you guys
thank you okay see you have a lot of
representation in the North Country this
year okay um there a represent of b b VI
I don't see her yet right she's still
not on
and okay uh representative
Fargo yeah hi I'm Christina Fargo
everyone calls me Tina um uh this is my
second term um on Commerce I'm from
Dover I represent W to um I love
Commerce it was my first second and
third choice so I'm really excited to be
back um I spent 25 years at Liberty
Mutual um primarily and their I division
um managing software um engineering and
development I have been married for 35
years I have two adult
children um that's kind of my story and
I'm excited to be back and it's nice to
see familiar faces
so
great okay uh so I see uh representative
Abel has has has signed on so good
morning Rich hi thank you thank you
John thank you very much um my name is
Rich Abel Richard Abel um I represent
Grafton
13 uh which is the the um boundaries of
the district are the same as the city of
Lebanon and this is my fourth term on on
Commerce um you have to watch out if
you're a new person gets addictive you
uh keep finding that you want to keep
doing it um this has been a fascinating
has really been a fascinating uh
committee to be on because we covered so
many different things and we might know
a good deal about one but there are so
many other areas that maybe we've had no
contact with um so it's really it's
really interesting um uh one of the
things I hope that maybe we can oh I
also wanted to say that this is a
terrifically has been over the four ter
the three terms and now this one uh an
extremely affable group even though many
members have changed and even though we
often disagree on things we very often
find
consensus um or we're able to tweak
bills so that we can find
consensus um and people always get along
um so I hope that that that will
continue but I also hope that uh if it's
possible we may be able to identify the
bills where there is pretty much
agreement and sort of put them in one
category
and find ways of of of of of coming to
to consensus and have others that where
we need to work harder we can kind of
spend more time on that but uh really
great to meet new people and uh look
forward to work thank you great thank
you um okay then uh representative
yourself uh you
you he disappeared oh cook yeah that's
that's him right he see yeah he's I
think representative aberson is is using
his um ability to name
himself oh I see he's the way of
communicating I'm not sure okay
creative cretive well thank you Max
third term and uh
see okay uh and then last but not least
is Keith Amon from Seattle he's still
going he's from Seattle
cool are you are you all done yet Max
I didn't even know you could do
that figure out how to do that okay I
think he's done all right so uh Keith
you want to introduce yourself yeah
sorry my my uh video is not working um
Keith Ammon this my third term uh first
time on Commerce uh I've heard so much
uh so many great things about this
committee and not to suck up but also
about the
chairman uh I've had buddies on this
committee Like Mike costable Elizabeth
Fiera uh Jason Osborne Bart
fouth uh and
others uh this is my third term in the
house uh I was previously on Municipal
and County and science technology and
energy which was like the committee next
door to you guys uh and we heard you
guys uh laughing and having fun uh in a
previous term so that made me want to
uh join the committee uh preo when we
actually could
meet uh commerce was my first
choice uh so the district I run in is a
floal it's uh Hillsboro District 40 I
live in New Boston and I represent New
Boston Mount Vernon
Milford and
Hollis uh I'm a computer geek uh
self-talk computer
programmer uh I specialized in
uh platforms and uh projects that uh
represent the the pharmaceutical
industry so I've I've written uh
applications for the Viagra Salesforce
before I needed it and uh and other
fazer projects uh sephylon
and a few other uh pharmaceutical names
that you might know I recently got my
pilot's license
uh so I have a small four-seater uh
Piper Warrior which is kind of fun to
fly around
in
and uh I also like to play guitar and my
wife Susan is from Hong Kong she has uh
witnessed her home
country become a uh communist
hellhole recently and I hope that
doesn't happen to us in the states and
especially not here in New Hampshire so
uh that's a little bit about me okay
thank you all right and um and I guess
just to round it out Pam do you want to
kind of introduce yourself to I don't
know does everybody know who you are yet
I mean it's a Well everybody's gotten
emails from me or or phone calls so I I
um I hope you know I knew who I was I
I'm not sure I introduced myself well in
in my emails but my name is Pam Sparling
um I have been working with the Commerce
Committee since I started at the
legislature um 31 years
ago uh and so it's I my other committees
all the researchers you'll discover um
have four or or generally four
committees so I'm not always present in
the room but with zoom it might be a
different story I might be able to be
multiple Place places at once more
easily so my my other committees are are
Edna election law and legislative
Administration um and I've I've always
of course loved Commerce and um and as
provide nonpartisan research primarily
at the direction of the chairman and
work with the with any subcommittees as
well so that's enough about me I guess
the emphasis there is that if if there's
something you would like to have Pam
work on you do need to go through me to
get permission to do that so um over oh
right on schedule um so briefly for
those who who've been on the committee
um know that historically uh Commerce we
would uh break up into three
divisions um we had uh Banking and
business uh we have uh insurance and
then we have liquor um and and
Hospitality type of legislation
um it it it is my intent um given that
we're what we're doing here with this co
uh being all uh virtual that um I I'm
going to try to we subcommittee is
really to a minimum at all and that
we're going to uh instead if a bill
needs to be really worked on and and we
can get somewhere um my feeling is that
we should just retain it and that and
that way when we retain bills that means
we'll come back in in in September
October is when uh we would then be able
to do our normal study committee sub
subcomittee type work and God I hope
this thing is we'll have our vaccines
and we got our her immunity by then and
so that we all can meet face to face
because I I just can't imagine a
subcommittee virtually you know we you
our subcommittees are very active we
allow everybody to participate and and
sometimes the room can be packed full of
people so uh trying to do that virtually
is going to be a nightmare um otherwise
um any bills that we pretty well can see
you know which way they're going whether
we want to pass it or or or kill it
we'll you know we'll move for in
expedient and get those bills out um but
so don't be surprised if if uh we have
the largest retained list than we've
ever had before but we've had some big
lists in the past so um Commerce is a
committee is we has a history we really
work our bills hard um we don't we don't
we don't want to hear people think the
bill needs to be recommitted back to
committee we certainly don't want to see
the Senate mucking up our handiwork and
on the other side of the coin uh we have
done um many Senate bills we have done
the hard work that they maybe um weren't
weren't didn't have the time to do then
they send it to us to fix it and that's
and that's what we do you know we we fix
bills and we do good job and that's the
reason why we get more bills than any
other committee and why we have such a
wide range um is uh going way back to
Donna sitech um she you know recognize
that this committee does really great
work so we will keep uh pursuing that
direction all right so now being 10:47
so we'll start out with our first
Department which is the insurance
department so I guess um uh Mr
commissioner and Deputy Commissioner if
you of all the insurance department
people um raise their
hand if you all raise your hand then I
can you will all jump to the top of my
list and then I can uh activate you oh
my God look at all you
guys you want me to work on some as
well uh okay well I guess I want to
practice so um okay so I'll start out
with the commissioner first here and I'm
uh Chris I'm gonna allow you to
talk and I see
are okay you're you're on
great uh thank you I think Tyler's going
to share our presentation if he's
already been um uh added he we have a a
short slideshow okay I just I just
on yeah so now I'm going to try and
share my screen you're
echoing I don't know if you got
something two things on maybe are they
fun okay so I can't see how I can share
my screen it's uh are you able to I can
share all panelists should be able to
share their screens but I can share um
my screen I've got
the Departments
with um I did not promote him to
panelists okay all right so let me
promote him to panelist okay oh okay
that's why that's why okay so I
permitted him to speak but I didn't hit
promote the panelist
okay would you rather that I get out of
this and you do the sharing Tyler um no
no I I need all the handholding I can
get okay so all right so U you want to
go ahead Ty I see I see it on the screen
why don't you introduce yourself and
Okay Tyler are you
there I think I think I'm up first guys
um okay go ahead Chris so perfect Tyler
can you go ahead and Advance the slide
one um I first off I want to thank you
chairman hunt and members of the
committee for this time and opportunity
to introduce myself uh and some key
members of the staff uh though there are
eight or nine folks on the call I'll
just be introducing uh three others to
briefly introduce themselves um on the
screen there you'll see our mission and
I think the core part uh is to pre
public good by ensuring the existence of
a safe and competitive Insurance
Marketplace uh and we're committed to
doing that in an honest effective and
timely manner uh that kind of is our
overriding uh Mission and our goal when
working with uh uh any of our
constituencies um for those of those of
you who don't know me my name is Chris
nicolopoulos and I've been a
commissioner here at the department of
insurance for 10 months um 10 days after
um I started we went into remote uh
covid world and so it's been an
interesting almost year at this point uh
but as I uh think back uh to my time
working with the Commerce Committee I
think this will be my 18th legislative
session working in some role uh with the
committee uh prior to uh accepting the
position as uh Commissioner of Insurance
I spent uh five years working with the
New Hampshire independent Insurance
Agents
Association um commissioner if I can
interrupt for a sec I'm not controlling
the slides I think Pam still has that
and I think we want to advance to the
next one Pam do you want to give me the
chance to do that or do you want to
continue because I keep getting a
message I can't share my screen while
another participant is
sharing okay fine I'm I'm gonna stop
sharing and then you'll be able to
share so prior to my time uh with the
Independent Insurance Agents I spent uh
six years with the law firm of pretty
flarity and in that role I represented
Insurance uh consumers and a few
insurance companies at the
legislature uh and prior to that I spent
five years working with New Hampshire
Realtors so in all of those roles I have
been uh intimately involved in uh a
number of the bills that the Commerce
Committee um has worked on and it's
surprising to see this year how many new
faces there are I look forward to
building a relationship uh with all of
you uh um the Department of Insurance
currently has 76 staff members um there
are 85 authorized positions but we we
typically have uh 10 to 15 uh open
positions uh and that's what we have now
later on today I will introduce DJ beton
Court who as of this Friday will be our
new Deputy uh commissioner uh he was uh
gracious enough to join us a couple of
days early so he could uh meet all of
you and I think many you know him in his
role his previous role as policy uh
director for the governor's office and
prior to that a number years in the in
the uh in the Hampshire house uh Christy
rice is on the call listening in uh
she's our assistant commissioner here at
the department and uh internally she
handles most of our operational uh uh
teams uh Marty Mobley um is on the call
uh many of you know her she is a
legislative uh assistant here at the a
coordinator at the uh department and uh
really manages all of our uh legislative
and Regulatory uh work and so oftentimes
she's the the Wizard behind the curtain
making sure we all show up at the right
place and that you all have the data
that that you need uh Tyler Brandon
who's on the call with us now um is our
director of Health
economics um James Fox is the director
of PNC and he'll speak in a bit
Christian Callahan who is our chief
actuary uh we have Doug Bartlett who
will also speak for a minute and he's
the director of financial reg and we
have Emily dhy who's our PNC legal
counsel the Hampshire has a lot of
distinctions but in the insurance World
it has the distinction of being the
first Insurance regulatory insurance
department established by state and that
was uh 170 years ago uh in 1851
uh primarily when you're dealing with
insurance laws uh those laws will be uh
between RSA 400 and
420n those are the regulations that our
department um is is uh responsible
for um and I think it's important to
note at this point that um Insurance
primarily is regulated at a state basis
um and uh for PNC especially uh
virtually all regulation happens here at
the state um and so that means this
legislature needs to give us Authority
on how to uh enforce and regulate
Insurance um and very much the same in
life and health it's regulated at the
state level uh though uh with the
Affordable Care Act and some
requirements that come down from the
federal government um the some of the
provisions are uh enumerated there at
the federal government but the
enforcement of virtually all of those
level as a department uh we collect um
roughly 130 to $140 million a year in
New Hampshire general fund Revenue the
vast vast majority of that is uh premium
tax uh premium taxes collected in
advance every March uh and that's
roughly 120 million of the 134 million
uh additionally we collect licensing
fees from a number of folks uh in
administrative
fines the department itself is not
generally funded uh our entire
department is run on an assessment
that's charged to any insurance company
that sells Insurance here in New
Hampshire and oversimplifying it uh we
look at the total number
of uh premium dollars sold to New
Hampshire Insurance consumers and a
fraction of a fraction of a percentage
is assessed to uh run the department um
which is an appropriate way to fund a
department that's regulating an industry
um we run we run pretty efficiently as
compared to other states um and we do so
all without any impact on general fund
uh
expenses when you think of our
department as a um as a regulatory of
all licenses uh it's staggering how many
folks are are actually licensed here in
in New Hampshire uh for for Insurance
Producers that uh folks that sell um PNC
or life and health insurance we have
6,500 uh resident licenses which seems
like a lot but there are some
91,000 out ofate producers licensed to
sell insurance to a residents here in
New Hampshire and for any producer if
they want to sell any business to a New
Hampshire a consumer or a Hampshire
business they must obtain a producers
license here in New Hampshire uh
similarly there's a nearly 800 adjusters
adjusters generally work for insurance
companies uh to uh resolve and and
settle claims we have 800 resident
licenses and um 75 almost 76,000
non-resident
lienes um those licenses um are employed
by some 600 resident businesses or 7,000
uh non-resident um foreign uh businesses
is uh each of those uh each of those
licenses require staff here to review um
accept payment for and approve
um additionally we have a division of
our department that uh reviews approves
or denies each and every policy form uh
that an insurance company might want to
use here in New Hampshire and so it
might be the uh the different forms that
are mailed to you each year when you get
your home or Auto policies it may be the
underlying rating uh structure how they
establish U uh their policy rating we're
we're reviewing and approving those to
make sure they're not
discriminatory um that they're
uh consumer appropriate um and in
compliance with our laws um so those are
you know hundreds of thousands or
millions of pages of documents that we
need to to review we also have divisions
here at the department that look at
Financial examination and Analysis
for any insurance company that's doing
business with a New Hampshire consumer
we're looking at their uh their
financial statements to make sure one
that they're appropriately uh filed but
also that they have sufficient um
Financial wherewithal to pay claims that
um that consumers can have confidence
that their uh Financial solvency will
not impact um their underlying insurance
contract um we have a division here that
does Market conduct analysis and exam
and what that's doing is uh these are
investigators that go into companies to
make sure uh one uh proactively we go in
to just make sure that they're working
in compliance with our laws that they're
rating policies fairly that they're
fairly uh paying claims uh and that
they're doing so in compliance with
their underlying forms uh and those
sometimes we do that proactively uh just
as a test uh if we have consumer
complaints or concerns and and there's a
reason for us to do a targeted Market
conduct exam we have the ability to do
that as
well we have a a couple folks here at
the department who uh handle insurance
fraud uh referrals and and each year we
get about 240 insurance fraud referrals
generally from companies who see really
uh suspicious claims but sometimes those
come from friends and families and
neighbors who are aware that somebody uh
may be committing insurance fraud and
our investigators will uh will look at
uh those referrals and if uh if
appropriate we'll investigate have um
have interviews with folks um we don't
um we don't prosecute uh insurance fraud
and so what will happen in those cases
is if if there appears to be insurance
fraud we prepare the case turn it over
to a county attorney uh who then um will
prosecute violations of the law
uh last year and typically last year we
referred 24 cases for prosecution and
that's in line with uh a typical
year um we hold for all those lenses the
the near 200,000 lenses that are
licensed here in New Hampshire um if uh
if we're aware that somebody has
violated a a rule requirement we have
folks here who can um investigate uh
violations of the of their license
um and ultimately we can hold hearings
here to determine what the appropriate
um punishment if if there is a
violation um and then finally we hold
public hearings on things like workers
comp premium rates uh cost drivers uh
for health
insurance um I think most importantly uh
what we do here in in uh the department
or at the department is protect
consumers uh in any given year our
consumer team uh will um have almost
5,000 consumer inquiries and that could
be anything as simple as I don't
understand what actual cash value is on
my policy um or uh questions about how
claims work uh to uh to actual uh
consumer complaints that are filed with
the department so of the 5,000 inquiries
we get a year uh that go to our consumer
team uh about 700 or 800 are turned into
complaints and those are uh people who
are unhappy with some part of an
insurance transaction who want our
experts to work with uh the companies or
the
adjusters um to determine uh whether or
not they've been treated fairly or
appropriately and though most of those
uh most of those interactions are uh
education of the educational variety um
last year we we documented um over a
million dollars in uh consumer harm that
we were able to that we're able to uh to
correct and uh and in a year that number
could jump you know if there's a life
insurance policy it could easily be
hundreds of thousands of dollars that we
help someone collect but but most of
those are small um disputes regarding uh
an explanation of benefits from a health
insurance company to um how to
appropriately value a total loss on a a
an
automobile um I think those that's a
place where we can be particularly
effective to Consumers who don't know
where else to turn uh it's an Avenue
that's available to Consumers uh short
of having to hire a lawyer to uh protect
their interests um and our team we have
seven members who are on that team um do
those jobs because they love of helping
uh helping
you're as uh Commerce Committee members
you are bound to hear in the next two
years of the NAIC or the National
Association of insurance
Commissioners uh I talked before about
how uh almost all insurance is at the
state-based
level um and because of that it has
become necessary for insurance
Commissioners like myself to work
together to ensure that uh we're
benefiting from the kind of uh Universe
of expertise Across the Nation and so
NAIC serves in that role it is insists
Insurance
Regulators um in serving public interest
and achieving a mission and how that
generally comes out is that NAIC will uh
work on model uh Insurance
regulation uh that states can use to
deal with um issues as they pop up and
so oftentimes you will C uh an niic
model that we're asking you to consider
because uh it is a better mous strap for
dealing with uh the ever evolving uh
insurance
issues and then finally I think it's
important to understand how we view uh
the department as a resource to your
committee um as a department we will uh
on occasion and this year I think we
have five or six bills that we're asking
to be sponsored and ped and when we do
that it's because we perceive that
something needs to be fixed in our laws
that as insurance develops that we need
to bring it to uh the current uh
practice of insurance and so we will
bring uh edits to our current laws
because we think it's necessary to
continue regulating the industry when we
do that um we will work with all the
constitu constituencies ahead of time in
the summer we share drafts that we're
working on with over 200 uh folks that
are interested in uh Insurance
regulation and we work with them so that
we understand the pros and cons of those
bills uh this year specifically uh we
took uh we took uh extra concern to
ensure that the bills that were asking
to be passed were particularly
non-controversial uh there were a couple
of issues that we were looking at uh
introducing that folks were concerned
about and because of the co environment
we're in we removed those as uh
potential bills for this year because we
weren't sure that there would be
appropriate uh time to kind of flesh out
all those concerns and so the bills that
the department is asking for I hope you
will find to be uh particularly
non-controversial
uh and even though only a few of the
bills that will participate in with this
committee are ours you will see someone
from the Department on virtually every
every insurance bill sitting uh in the
room or in a zoom meeting
nowadays um because we are uh we are we
should be resources to all of you to
help understand the
impact uh for those of you that don't
know the department we almost always
will start testifying on a bill by
saying the department doesn't have a
position and then we'll go on to talk at
length about either all the wonderful
things or all the issues that a
particular bill um present presents um
and we we are 100% aware that the policy
decision is going to be made at your
committee and in in the House and Senate
um but as experts it's our role to tell
you what uh what the hurdles are uh what
the benefits and ultimately what the
hurdles are of those bills and and we
will take strides not to uh not to take
a position but to fairly uh in an
unbiased and non-political matter uh
share those uh Resources with
you um that's the end of my presentation
I'd like to to toh introduce Doug
Bartlett who's gonna talk a little bit
about financial rig I'm happy to answer
questions but I'm sure there'll be time
at the end to do that as
well okay hi I'm can everybody oh go
ahead John yeah I was just gonna say so
I we I can hear you and do I need to now
I guess we're good to go yeah I mean I
don't see I don't see your smiling face
but
are you are you going to use a
presentation here also is Tyler Run it's
just the next slide okay perfect all
right go
ahead okay um my name is Doug Bartlett
I'm the director of financial regulation
and my
division is to ensure the solvency of
New Hampshire markets and keep the state
of New Hampshire accredited by the neic
we have 62 domestic companies those are
companies that are Incorporated in New
Hampshire and we also
regulate uh 1,00 123 Foreign Insurance
companies and for the you those of you
that are new on the company a foreign
company just means it's from another
state opposed to a foreign country which
be an alien so when you when you hear me
talk about foreign companies I'm talking
about companies that are domiciled in
other states we do examinations on
insurance companies on on our on our
domestics once every five years we have
a analysis Department that works for me
that analyzes all of these um mostly our
62 domestics but we also look at the
other companies too and that's that's a
continual annual annual and quarterly
[Music]
review we uh also uh license companies
and other
entities such as the tpas that uh
commissioner nicolopoulos uh mentioned
before and we also have oversight of
Ensure rehabilitations and insolvencies
okay sorry about that I didn't know I
was supposed to do the unting part um
can everybody hear me now we can hear
you great okay my name is James Fox I'm
the PNC director um you know the
commissioner did such a great job with h
kind of the run through of the
department um I think I'll focus more on
the people uh so I've been with the
department for nine years I started as a
PNC attorney and I've been the PNC
director for about four years um
property casualty uh I think most people
probably more easily think about that a
property and liability insurance so
that's uh your auto insurance your
homeor insurance umbrella coverage
professional liability basically
anything that's property that you're
trying to protect or liability in case
you hurt somebody else's property or
somebody another person uh that's what
we handle in PNC um our our really
department has three prongs the the
first two prongs are primarily front end
that's we review all a lot of the
insurance forms that are used in the
state to make sure they're compliant
with our regulatory laws and uh we also
look at the rates to make sure they're
not uh inadequate uh and not
discriminatory and then on the back end
uh we um have a market conduct unit uh
and that unit uh goes into the insurance
companies and they make sure as it says
that the conduct of the insurance
companies is consistent with our laws
that have been obviously passed by the
legislature um that's and then the other
thing we do obviously do consumer
complaints and I will sit in all
consumer complaints and review every
single one of them along with the PNC
attorney Emily dhy um the commissioner
the PNC team that's uh myself as the PNC
director chrisan citarella who's the
actuary uh he knows all about rates and
uh adequate inadequate um discrimination
all that and then Emily dhy uh who's our
attorney uh and she if we have any legal
questions that we're unsure about um we
go to her uh and she helps us with that
so as to testimony uh you'll hear
probably from all three of us and
sometimes the multiples and then um you
know this year things that outside of
our bills things that we probably will
be over there on that come to mind are
there's a a bill in an auto minimum
limits that we have something to say
about there's a new bill again back
that's on travel insurance that will
have something to say about and there's
another one comes to mind is the storage
facilities uh producer licensing
requirements so that's um basically uh
who I am and who our little team is also
at you know at the department we have
probably 15 people that do PNC and
probably hundreds of years of experience
so we do have a lot of knowledge uh and
we uh all love PNC and we look forward
committee right excuse me Mr chairman I
just want to break in and and I see that
um Doug and the commissioner both have
turned their video on and I think that
that's that's helpful and and anybody
who's a panelist will have the uh
ability to turn their their video on so
I wasn't sure that they yeah
okay do that or qu do that right it all
depends if you have a camera of course
right well I can see your name but I
don't see your picture I I turned myself
off I'm in the background but I'm here
okay all
right um all right commissioner who's
who's up next I am John it's Tyler
Brandon
of Health economics with the Department
I've had a few different titles with the
department and uh I'm real familiar I
think to folks like representative hun
and some of the others that have been on
the the committee for a while um we've
had some staff changes on the life and
health side but you should feel free to
to contact me on on any of those related
issues do what the commissioner needs me
to do on that front and um happy to
provide kind of the policy input to this
committee as I have in the past um we do
a lot of the same work on the life and
health as we do on the property and
Casualty side the market conduct the
form review the rate review uh what I
have listed here are some of the the
main topic areas you're likely to see
legislation um in front of this
committee on and one of the things
that's a little unique about that the
life and health um or at least the
health particularly since the passage of
the ACA is we're constantly thinking
about the the interaction between
federal and state laws and U with the
ACA has set certain Market rules that
all the states had to follow that that
being said there's still a fair amount
of flexibility at the state level we
just need to make sure that we don't run
into issues of federal preemption and
those ACA Market rules tend to to be
most relevant for the exchange products
for the individual Market um that being
said we're always thinking about our
Market stability which has a lot to do
with the underlying risk selection you
are likely to see bills that come before
you expanding coverage one way or
another um there's traditional Insurance
mandates that change the scope of
services after to be covered but you
will also see a lot of other legislation
that looks at kind of first dollar cost
sharing as Services um are trying to be
protected keep the patient out of it
those types of legislation do run up
against sometimes tax laws we do try to
provide some insight on that front
clearly it's not our expertise but um
tele medicine prescription drugs are big
cost driver or at least the prescription
drugs are a big cost driver area tele
medicine is obviously a topic of
Interest particularly lately and
expanding access to those types of
services so you're probably going to see
legislation on that front if not this
year um in the next couple of years one
of the other areas that comes up all the
time is price transparency and I am
happy to say that the insurance
department has been a national leader on
this front with our New Hampshire Health
cost website where we have been posting
the actual price of health care services
for um what is actually about 14 years
and uh that's received a lot of national
attention it is often given as a reason
not to require Health Care Providers or
carriers to do something instead uh that
being said there are new federal
requirements coming down the pipe for
both providers and insurers finally we
are actually statuto required to put on
an annual hearing every year that
focuses on premiums and cost drivers as
a part of that we produce a great report
that has a lot of data in detail um
about our markets market share cost
drivers and uh you will hear me refer to
that report to provide you with
information that is going to be relevant
um to the legislation that you may be
considering so that's a a very quick
summary of a lot of information that I
know this committee is gonna looking at
uh in the next year or two but at this
point I'm G to pass it on to our our new
Deputy Commissioner DJ and um always
happy to answer questions uh and you
will get my contact info I think as
everybody else who's presenting at the
insurance department and happy to help
um as much as we
can great thank
you great well thank you Tyler and good
morning to the house Commerce Committee
is my volume okay chairman hunt it works
good very good thank you sir well my
name is DJ Benton courton as the
commissioner noted earlier I have just
recently joined the Department coming
over from the governor's office my first
day here at the department will be this
coming Friday I am very excited to be
joining the department as the Deputy
Commissioner and as you have seen from
the presentation today I am really I'm
joining a really great team of people uh
obviously I bring a bit of a unique
perspective to this process in that I
previously served in the legislature so
I know what it is like to sit on your
side of the table or in this case on
your side of the screen and one of the
things that I know is so important in
your role and that so many of you Pride
yourselves on is your constituent
service work and as this uh slide here
indicates the department is here as a
resource to you we have an outstanding
consumer protection division that the
commissioner described to you earlier
and they can assist you in in
troubleshooting any constituent service
issues that that come up uh or any
questions that you yourselves may have
uh please do not be afraid to contact
them in some cases they'll be able to uh
have an answer for you in that moment uh
but if not they're going to be able to
track down the answer or the information
that you're looking for or put you in
touch with the individual within the
department uh that can help you and
obviously I can help uh get you in touch
with anyone here uh as well as the
commissioner any member of the team uh
should you need anything uh so that is
what I have to share with you briefly
this morning and I look forward to the
opportunity to work with you whether it
is in this venue or when the world
returns to some normaly in person uh so
with that I will turn it over to the
commissioner
thanks DJ and thanks to the rest of the
team uh that went uh pretty timely um
I'm happy to share my direct dial with
the committee members uh here at the
office uh it's
3945 um that'll get you right to my desk
and my uh work cell is
4583 uh you truly can use those numbers
anytime you need us
um I'll get you to the right people
we're happy to answer any questions you
might have but I think just leave here
knowing that we're a resource to you all
so I guess the first thing is this uh
presentation I hope you you'll guys will
send this PDF to to us so that we we all
have that with all the already has it uh
we had tried to I had hoped to be able
to link it into the the text box but I
don't see how I can do that but we have
already sent it to Pam ahead of time so
maybe she can get it out to the
committee get it out to okay all right
Absolutely I'll send that and the
contact list to all of you today right
probably right in a few minutes but
we'll we'll
see good okay um so uh now we'll we'll
try something even more daring we'll ask
the committee members if they have any
questions so if a committee member has a
question raise your hand and uh and and
I'll recognize you to ask your question
to the
department any
questions um in the meantime um just my
my overview of insurance and and and I
know you know they did excellent job in
presenting it but um the things that I'd
like to emphasize to everyone is that um
the the initial purpose and as they
described it was that it was solvency
solvency is really a critical element of
what our department is supposed to be
doing is making sure a company is
charging enough rates so often people
will say well why aren't we regulating
rates why don't we telling them to to
stop raising their rates and none of
this and that's not really actually what
our our mission our mission is to is to
make sure that they can make those
payments make the um you know the
payouts that they're responsible for um
health insurance is different um I often
say to everybody um health insurance is
not insurance
because um as compared to property and
casual I hope never to make a claim I
hope my house never burns down and I
know my car never gets stolen um whereas
health insurance we all need it we all
use it it's a you know it's an employer
benefit originally it was you know there
I remember the days when health
insurance was actually a throwin it was
actually u a life insurance policy you
got you know employer would provide a
$10,000 life insurance policy to her
employees and the health insurance was
sort of an add-on to it um that was a
long long time
ago compared to manag care today um so
we we do have some regulatory system in
place for uh rates when it comes to
health insurance um that is federally
mandated and and in that case it is the
maximum amount of Premium they can
charge um and it is based upon their uh
payout and percentages that they're
allowed to keep for their operating you
know 10 to 15 I forget for individual
and in group or something you know is
that right am I got it got that right
yeah it's either 15 or 20 depending on
the size right 15 or 20 okay so and so
there there is some maximums and and so
or like I say health insurance is it's
it's a stretch to call it insurance but
uh NE to say it is it is something that
takes a lot of our time a lot of what
goes on with the Department is is
related to insurance and I would say um
the vast majority of our our health
insurance of our insurance bills usually
have some health related to it and
that's why we know Tyler and and so
Tyler you said 14 years since that
that's been wasn't that your program so
that that make me know that you've been
years that's correct I'm getting close
to 15 will'll be uh this year in 2021
and put up the website within six months
um of me being here so uh yeah and kind
of a pretty small operation just we use
the clams data which uh was the result
of legislation um that did go through
this committee
requiring the insurers and tpas to send
anonymous claims to the state and the
insurance Authority and we use those
detailed claims data to to show rates
that are actually paid to the provider
not just charges and um that would allow
patients to understand their liability
particularly if they have a high
deductible Health Plan and um yeah so um
CNN New York Times Wall Street Journal
um every major media has covered our
Effort New Hampshire on this front well
think to your ering on that so it's it's
great um and I still don't have any
hands raised so I don't know if nobody
wants to ask any questions DJ welcome uh
it's great to have you and seeing you uh
there and uh we obviously DJ and I go
way back when in the legislature and uh
he never did get to serve on Commerce
but uh but he was a a majority leader
for a peri of time yeah yes John
represent thank you thank you Mr
chairman uh first of all it's great to
be back and working with all you guys in
the insurance industry uh it's been
enjoyable over the past years that I
worked and Marty it's nice to see you uh
in insurance now it was great to working
with you on the new bills and looking
forward to hopefully back in person come
come
springtime um helpful to remind people
that in order to raise your hand hand
electronically which is is really the
preferred method um you need to select
the
participants uh list and at the bottom
of the participants list there's an
option to raise your hand and it it may
be different depending on what kind of
device you're you're using but that is
the the most usual um on our Max here we
have the we have raised hand that's on
our main
screen okay it it hopefully is is
somewhere easy to find I know sometimes
it's upper right um sometimes it's at
the very bottom of the participant um
list and there's a there are three dots
that give um more options
and if if you look around and get used
to where you um where it is on your
screen that that'll be useful for right
a long time so right so yeah so Marty do
you want to introduce yourself to
everybody so they know uh what important
role you play in the insurance
department
well certainly thank you uh chair H I'm
Marty Moy I'm the legal coordinator here
at the insurance department I'm the
person that will be reaching out to
folks um in the fall time frame when I'm
looking for sponsors for our legislation
um and I also well when we're in person
I attend the hearings and I also bring
along with me the uh subject matter
expert whether it's um James Fox or
Emily dhy for PNC or or James I mean
Tyler Brandon for LA and uh Doug Doug
always comes for anything that's on
financial regulation um Heather
Silverstein is our general counsel she's
also on the call today uh she's just
raising waving her hand she uh sometimes
accompanies me to the hearings if we
have something that is of a of a a
technically legal nature so that she can
explain things in more detail for people
and I'm always here as a resource if
people need to get in touch with
somebody at the department and they
don't know who to contact they can
contact me and I can figure out who they
need to talk to yeah I can't emphasize
that enough that you know you you are
the kind of the go-to person for for the
legislative
process
so okay uh anybody else the insurance
department I guess I don't know Heather
do you want to say say anything
or say hello hi can you hear me yep uh
it's nice to see everybody uh like most
of us I really would like to see you in
person
uh so uh I look forward to that time
again when we can all meet in person um
I just a shout out to Marty this has
been an unusual year and Marty's been
able to adjust and juggle as best as we
can uh trying to figure out um how we go
about doing our normal business in a
year that's not typical and so uh she's
done a really great job and we really
appreciate her at the department um and
we also are very happy with Chris he's
been here for 10 months felt really bad
for him 10 days in he's hit with a
pandemic um but I have to say he is a
boots on the ground kind of guy uh
unbelievable as far as that goes he
knows everybody in the department he
knows what we do he has really made an
ex extrordinary effort to get to know
everybody and understand the jobs of the
department so that is really telling of
how he is and how he wants to run the
department so I will give a shout out to
him at this time as well and um thank
you all okay thank you representa mcleer
I see you have your hand up yeah I have
a question sort of a a personal question
um when I moved to New Hampshire I had
had a non-resident Life Health variable
license in New Hampshire for I don't
know 25 years and when I tried to turn
it into a res license I was told I had
to go through the whole process again
which meant 40 hours of classroom why
was that I sort of never understood
that okay who wants to take on
surprise representative unfortunately I
don't have someone from our licensing uh
Team on this call um if you want I I'm
happy to look into it if you still have
that non resident license that
potentially is subject to no I had to I
had to give that up but I I you know
when I moved to other states they've
honored it and the Hampshire was the
only one that didn't unless somebody
told me wrong well how how long ago was
this oh this was five years ago oh
because we've we've been more recently
upgrading our our reciprocity yeah it it
just didn't seem to me to be right I I
could change my driver's license right
away but uh you know it was at my age it
was too much to take sitting in a
classroom for another 40 hours so anyway
if yeah I would I would like to know
maybe that's something you've changed
absolutely said send them send him an
email and remind him so he'll I'm sure
he'll get you a reasonable answer for
that one all right thank you yes for
producers f2j is the statute that we
refer to so I can't think of it off the
top of my head but that's the statute
that we that we start with we're
producers and Joan lorse is our
specialist with regard to producer
department I'll get an answer and send
you an email this afternoon
good all right uh well thank you all
very much uh I appreciate it and uh
we'll look forward to seeing you when
when we hit the ground running with
bills so thank you guys uh all right so
for the committee members um uh okay
we're we're done for lunch and lunch I I
try to schedule this up so we don't
spend too much time in front of the our
computers here um so we'll do the
banking Department in 115 um but the
last last thing I'd like to do is give
you guys all a little bit of a homework
homework assignment and That is um you
don't have to do it today obviously
because or tomorrow because you might
want to hear all the different builds um
in different issues but uh I will still
create my standing three divisions so
that is Insurance uh Banking and
business
and liquor and
Hospitality um the banking business also
includes Condos for people who are
condos or or time sharing representative
ham I remember you had a time sharing
bill in the committee many years ago but
um so any those are the three different
divisions and obviously probably best to
hear all the Department's presentations
then before you want to make a decision
which one you want to go to um but like
I said
earlier I don't plan to have too much
subcommittee work you know I just can't
imagine unless it's really just tweaking
little things but that will generally uh
retain retain everything till September
uh representative Bartlett you have your
hand
up um I'm sorry I've got a one o'clock
Zoom um so I won't be able to be here at
one okay all right well you you know
about the banking Department
yeah and I assume you want to be on the
insurance insurance subdivision division
anyways
so please uh put me on insurance um and
if anybody's wondering I am still
knitting I didn't get to knit as much
this past term I did 34 pairs of mittens
um the first the first year of our
two-year term last last term I give them
way to daycare centers but we spend so
many hours sitting I just can't have I
have to do something okay so I do have
some more hands up uh Paul Terry
representative Terry yeah U Mr chairman
in uh in my past uh experiences it's
it's been typical uh when uh bodies or
uh committees are meeting to have a
projected uh ending time did did I
happen to miss that today I saw the
meeting began at 10: amm but I had no
idea how long the the day was going U
here's the bad news no we don't give you
ending
times reason well it's in general I
would say in general when it comes to a
hearing when we actually hear bills
we're going to tell you what time the
bill is scheduled for but no we don't
have an end dat because we never know
how long people were there and we um you
know we everyone gets an opportunity to
speak so that can go on forever and ever
so the big problems that might occur is
when bills uh are are start to overlap
another bill in terms of times and then
it's up to the chair to um maybe recess
and uh uh I would recess a hearing open
the other hearing announce when we would
then reschedule but again it's never in
end times I I wish it is funny you would
point that out I never really thought
about that we don't ever well that makes
the end times that makes eminently good
sense given the nature of the ongoing
work of the committee I was thinking
specifically of the orientation and a
program that had been developed for
today yeah so so um I I don't know the
schedule that was uh I assume was
emailed out him emailed it out but it
just has the starting time so you can
you can tell the end time is uh uh
either lunch the appropriate lunch hour
uh for today this so noon you know and
would have been and then so I give I
always try to give an hour and 15
minutes for lunch and then and so the
banking will get back together today at
1:15 for banking Department okay uh
representative patus uh two things uh
first I will volunteer for the liquor
subcommittee okay
and secondly uh when we're when we're
done here are we going to back in at 115
115 yes so you just log back the same
the same dial in that we used ear yes
same same okay thank you yep represent
of
Herbert how you doing there Chris on
your
mute unmute yourself Chris okay
um my question is uh and and and John po
will appreciate it is that there's a
tremendous amount of paperwork and
information that flows into this
committee and uh I sat next to John last
session and John had had I mean he spent
an an a crazy amount of time just making
sure he had everything just exactly
where it's supposed to
be uh how are we going to deal with uh
and John did a great job by the way I'm
complimenting him but uh um how are we
gonna handle
that this way hand out stuff so uh Pam
um what what's the latest on on our
ability to start to see copies of
handouts and
fors I don't really have a a a concrete
answer I know that that that bills will
you know certainly be easily distributed
to anybody who comes to conquer to meet
in the committee room but that's one of
the the the issues that is um not
settled as far as I know how much
material will be mailed to people's
homes um we hope to have a a a robust
system where we have an electronic file
with any you know testimony that's
submitted and you know accessible to the
committee members as we go forward
electronically but uh as far as hard
copies of every document well I don't I
don't think that's uh hard copies is is
uh the best way to go if you can get
somebody to have a digital library or a
digital folder that's the that's the
hope but it it I can't say it's it's
established um right this minute you
know so that's they're working working
on it and yes a work in progress in the
perfect world or what we hope the end
game is that um you we would be able to
have a library in which you can then go
search bills by there uh as though as
though you went into the committee room
and pulled out the folder right well
otherwise I have to go visit John every
day and I you know I I don't want to
burden him with uh
that all right uh representative van
Hoon how
Royal okay you got
one thank you just um I just want to let
you know that I to have a conflict this
afternoon and I will not be on the
afternoon session uh thank you for doing
this I want to welcome all of the new
members to Commerce I think it'll be an
enjoyable but challenging session for us
with the U kinds of work that we do um
and I will see you tomorrow I guess I
thought there was one other thing that I
was going to mention but um
it'll take a while to get back into the
Commerce Committee meeting mode so thank
you again and I'll see tomorrow yeah
just reminder everybody it's 9 o'clock
we're we're starting a little early
because we're going to get everything
done uh in the morning so okay
representative
Bartlett again this was an idea part of
our bills last year um just so people
have an idea do have you had any any
bills assigned yet Mr chair so if you
were to go on online um and I have not
done it today but online there would if
you go to the Advan search it says we
have 13 bills oh that's nothing I looked
this morning Mr chairman they're 37 37
they're
growing I think this was 70 70 some odd
I had to start another notebook last
just last term year before that was 91 I
had three 4 inch
binders and asked Chris we used to go
crazy trying to find all the bills
that's not everybody's point I don't
want to print them all
out all right representative ham yes I'm
just wondering when do you think we're
going to come to conquer to meet in
committee um you know the big room with
all of us spread uh around the room um
well any idea you came in a little later
but I I just want you to know what I
personally feel and that is that I I I
will not come to conquered or I have any
plans to come to conquered okay until I
have my
vaccine i i i the idea of being in a
room um right you know is is is uh my my
my wife the nurse told me that that I
can't do that I'm not allowed to do that
you know and I agree I I I've had my
first one uh I'm on to my second one so
you know I don't disagree I yeah I I I I
I don't disagree with that I just was
curious and um if now's a proper time
I'll sign up for that uh committee that
has the condo time share Bank business
one all right perfect good I I I was
hoping you didn't go that
way good okay uh I see no more
hands hi can you hear me yes I can um I
want to thank everybody I this was very
informative today and I want to request
to be on the liquor and
Hospitality okay P all right great so
we'll uh see you all oh and
representative mcle you you're uh you
put your hand back
up uh yes I did um uh Mr chairman I I
think I left your office a note that I
will not uh be available tomorrow I'm
sorry about that I've got something else
going on and also I think the right
committee for me would probably be the
insurance committee
okay thank
you okay and for the Mr chairman just
for the The Lunch Period oh I'm I'm
sorry I see representative Ammon has his
hand up I jumped in without raising my
hand I just wanted to tell everybody
that this meeting will continue to be
running I will leave it running and I'll
just post um a sign when you will we
will return so anybody coming on to
YouTube can see what what time time it
will resume so you can stay in if you
want and just turn your your video off
or um come back as you as you enter show
an empty chair yes but it'll be clear
that that you're you're coming back I
think important thing a bunch of empty
chairs would be a bad bad look I like
that okay uh representative Anon yeah I
I just I have a conflict at 2 o'clock
today so I'll be jumping off and I'll
just
be quiet about it letting everyone know
no problem all
right okay now it's not seeing any more
hands and it's 11:42 so what we adjourn
until
1:15 and have a good
for
I see you're still on Pam I am still on
I'm trying to get what do you see do you
see my whole I see Unbreak Commerce
Committee will return at 115 yeah but do
you see the whole um heading up here I
do I do yeah that's what I'm trying to
figure out why it's doing that and I why
it's not just the document but can't
toar yeah I need to hide the fold the
um you know the right how to skew go to
view there you go is that's better right
yep yep that's cool that's it's the
word so is there anything I meant to did
you see my email about sharing
screens I have not I did not look at any
emails no okay I I um I had hadn't told
you that when you when you enter the
meeting it's set so only the host can
share a screen but um because you know
the insurance department is much easier
if the if somebody else does it you know
if the person
talking all you need to do is go to the
the bottom center of the screen it says
share screen right where it says share
screen there's a little up carrot yep
and then it gives you that that you see
that the buttons for only host only host
or all panel all panelists so that's
that's how you do the screen
share so then anybody who's a panelist
can share now for some reason Tyler came
in as an attendee we made him you know
you made him a panelist and I couldn't
there was no option to return him to the
attendee list and I it's like he was he
was a permanent panelist so I I couldn't
change him so I just emailed him and
told him you're a panelist until you go
out and come back as an attendee you
know usually a panelist speaks and then
just leaves the meeting so it's not a
big issue but I don't know what that I
can't explain that well right now I'm
looking at the panel panelists and I
don't see him so he must have he must
have yeah I think he probably left at
lunchtime and if he comes I don't know
why he would come back for banking but
if he wanted to just for you know I
don't know why well I did I did see
Jerry little was on for
insurance um the other thing I wanted to
mention to you that I haven't told you
yet is that tomorrow I you know I think
I mentioned the reason we're starting at
9ine is because I have Edna at 10: right
right so that means I have to leave at
9:30 yeah but another researcher will
come on just so you have somebody to
assist okay and the other thing that I
have been doing is lowering hands if
people people raise their hands but they
they never lower remember to lower them
ah okay I was wondering how that how
that happened yeah yeah so it's it's
it's easy you you see in their little um
in their little panel where there once
was a hand it's just has lower hand and
you just click on that and that hands
down so you don't have too many hands
left up and you know you need them to be
sounds good all right okay so have a
good lunch you too take care bye bye
it
is
now
no you know just
everything
very some enforce that social and
enforce
just
[Music]
good
oh
representative
bolo hi I you can't hear I I'll uh turn
on hi I just wanted to say hi and I
you're muted
um mute there you go all right no I
didn't even realize I was a meeting
today oh no
oh I I sent the email and and left the
voice message but uh yeah um the
uh the calendar now I would like to
receive a calendar every week a hard
copy is that possible you would have to
talk to the clerk's office I don't I
don't know what the procedure is for
that yep so yep go ahead I was just
gonna say so you um how did you know to
come now did you see it in the calendar
and then wonder about the I think I just
was I was going out for a walk and uh I
looked at my phone and I think there was
a message maybe it was your your um
voicemail because it was from you um
yeah I just checked my my my phone oh
and and then you found it in your email
right and and this was just like 15
minutes
ago yeah I'm so sorry oh that's yeah
what you've missed is the insurance
department presentation and I I emailed
the their their slides to you and so
they'll come back and do banking this
afternoon and then tomorrow at 9 o'clock
you'll get um and I haven't sent the
9ine o'clock um link yet because I want
wait until this was you know until
Tuesday was over before I added
Wednesday to your your emails y so as
soon as the this meeting is over this
afternoon I'll send that out to
everybody and hopefully meting uh back
at 1:15 right yes and and uh there's a
meeting tomorrow at 9: yes all right
well that's
okay so is there a better a different
email address for you that I should use
um I think my home email would be the
best because I checked
those okay because you know we get so
many emails uh as a legislator on the
legislative you know account I I
completely understand I
mean but um let me give it to you okay
I'm ready yep h o u l i g
n
comcast.net okay all
lowercase yes okay Comcast I will um
change that for the future yeah because
I I check that every morning
okay and I know especially now you know
you haven't been getting legislative
emails necessarily and so to to check
all the boxes is um sometimes yeah most
of the emails are just you know just
junk mail it's amazing how many
companies um like Chris Cosmetics I get
an email three emails a day on my
legislative from her she's a company of
Makeup Company in in man you know I
don't how we should just see if we can
those all right we are still live
streaming on YouTube Just so you know
you know not not that you've said
anything inappropriate but you know I
what we've done is you know started the
meeting at 10 o'clock and it's just
running um and then I that not um Terri
Morris is she going to be working in the
office with you
Abby Carrie Morris correct um uh yes she
you're the research she's the secretary
yes yes she's coming back some some
sometime soon I mean we've you know as
you can imagine we've been in a bit of a
holding exact exactly how to staff you
know like what's happening but I heard
just I think yesterday that Carrie's
coming back soon okay all right um yeah
because I'll be seeing her well her
mother I uh so we have a meeting
tomorrow what about
Thursday no just um the two the two days
for Commerce today
okay okay good right I'll back at 115
okay great thanks you're
welcome all
right all right then
to
e
works what going away and coming back
yeah this the first time I've I've done
a redial back on the same Zoom notice so
gee can we use this for tomorrow
too you will
oh not this not this uh link no no no
tomorrow I have not sent tomorrow's link
yet because I didn't want there to be
any confusion about which was which and
so I fig you know if we get we can use
it to dial back in today can we use it
not I'm not a technology Guru so I'm
just asking a question yeah I know I I
know that the the basic hope um is that
we'll have a set link for Commerce
meetings perfect that's that's what I
was alluding to right right that is
absolutely so we don't have to have all
this did you get the email and you know
which address did it go to that you'll
be able to save a link for commerce's
Reserve block that's great that's that's
the hope but I know I know Keith might
be able to allude allude to more on the
well I think most people know more than
I do about how it all works yeah I know
zoom my question my question is there a
way for us to save that link within the
program or do we have to always go back
to the email to find the link
again well I think the hope would be
that you'd have a set link for your your
you know Commerce reserved time and that
you'd be able to save it you know
somewhere in a document
andwhere the same the same L yeah in
your calendar too yep yeah but the one
in the calendar is is the attendee link
the links that are emailed to you are
are I know but you could save that link
and say put it into your own personal
calendar oh I see what you're saying put
in your calendar not the house calendar
yeah
right that's based on the premise that
you keep a calendar on the
computer
yeah Joe I made a mistake you're
actually 40 years um younger than most
of us not 30 so I apologize for
that I only used to build computers at
digital I didn't work on the software oh
I worked at digital too really yeah I
worked at I worked at in marbor oh I was
at nio up in Salem okay I used to go
down to mro 3 when I was working
government
programs yeah I was AT3 M
MK2 I used to go down to DC a lot like
one week out of every month but starting
my meeting the only one I the only thing
I remember about digital was the grilled
corn muffins that caused me to gain 10
pounds oh yeah yeah remember we had
Legal Seafood in the cafeteria oh man
yeah oh that is awesome that was great
yeah but uh yeah I've quite a quite a
history as as
most constituents know for me it was the
chocolates in the Commerce um office
that had me gain five
pounds thank God I'm not close to the
chocolate jar anymore yeah when we when
we get back it'll be coffee and
chocolate again oh no no no no no oh yes
yes yes well remember when you eat them
during business hours they don't gain
weight yeah tell me about it
John uh so representative Terry you have
a question I see have your hand up yes
Mr chairman uh I I believe I recall that
there were
members uh in the morning session who
were expressing interest in subcommittee
assignments um yes was
could could you to do
that yeah well basically uh once You'
you know tomorrow once we do uh liquor
and
um security but but basically the three
divisions are
Insurance Banking and um Finance or and
and
condos and uh and liquor so there are
three three standing subcommittees three
standing we we call them
divisions um even though we're not like
finance that has real divisions with
real representation but this uh occurred
way back when Bill O'Brien was speaker
and they threatened to break Commerce up
and I I went on Bend and knee and say no
no no no no breaking up Commerce we're
you know and we can handle all this
legislation because there now we we've
always been the Lion Share of
legislation always close to 10% of all
the bills
and um so I the my proposal to him was
to create these divisions and that that
seemed to take the little bit of a
pressure off and but um in terms of just
my experience and the way I've done
things over the years um it would always
be kind of a a mishmash when you create
up a subcommittee I mean literally would
be uh back when when I Leo Frasier was
my chairman he would he would just look
in the room and look at three people and
and picked two Republicans one Democrat
and and you know there was a
subcommittee and then there was always a
struggle about scheduling the
subcommittee and getting things done so
um when I came up with this idea of
Divisions it just worked really Nifty
because we could schedule the all the
bill all the bills would go to that
division we would schedule it that group
of people can come and go in terms of
who they were it was bigger than three
so you used to have more bodies there
and and uh it always seemed to work
really well and then
out of that subcommittee would come the
decision of what we're going to do with
the bill so by the time we got to the
exec session U for the whole committee
to deal with bills unlike other
committees which you know which don't
get you know a they get a fraction of
our bills and when they would kind of
struggle it over and sometimes they
would then send it to subcommittee or
something like that we we could we were
very efficient we were we are the model
of efficiency when it came to Executive
session in terms of going through bills
and we've and it seemed to work well so
so it do I understand the difference
between a division and a subcommittee is
that it's less formal no it's the same
thing same thing so it's just semantic
it's just a different name exactly
exactly so actually there there are the
divisions are AKA sub subcommitte right
but having said that um I I I really
will it will
be I I think we'll rarely have any of
those meetings this this year
um next year it'll definitely be the way
we do things but at this point I I'm any
bill that's really going to need work
really need um you know really we're
going to talk about it more than then
casual you know we all can pretty much
get a consensus what we want to do with
bill okay uh I I guess I would ask the
members of the banking Department to
raise their hand so that we can put them
up on top of here here we go all right
so then I I'm going to promote to
panelists right
and and just to to mention rep um M Mr
chairman representative bolo has joined
us this afternoon she
um I heard she came in just as we all
left for a
l just wanted her to be make sure
everybody saw her and uh you know she
could be introduced
okay yeah good so um is she on right now
yes she was just waving oh there you are
hi Jane there she is okay so why don't
you unmute yourself and introduce
yourself to the
committee can you hear me okay yes we're
just a second Jerry we're gonna have
Jane do first and then we'll take you up
thank you sorry uh uh Jane B from um
representing the west side of Manchester
I've been in the house for um I think
this is my six 16th year and first time
on Commerce and uh happy to be here
thank
you did you choose to be on Commerce or
I I did I did because I've served on
three different committees over the LA
the last 15 16 years and uh I thought
Commerce would be a h a good change
great good well welcome the board thank
you uh okay uh we're ready for the B
commissioner so um commissioner you're
you're on thank you chairman hunt it's
nice to see you and to see a number of
the folks who have come back for this
session and to uh sort of meet all of
Vice chairman Pusa how are you um sort
of kind of Meet the new members of the
committee hopefully we'll get a chance
at some point in time to uh to actually
say hello in person I am Jerry little I
have been State Bank commissioner since
2016 uh when I was uh appointed um
by a a quick background I'm about a
40-year denisen of the State House Halls
myself having um and I didn't realize
until uh I listened to folks uh
introduced themselves this morning um
how much that I had incommon with
representative Herbert in that uh I
started my work around the state house
in the early 80s as a state House
reporter hanging out in the Press Room
with Don Tibbits uh and then in ' 87
um moved to Governor John H sununu's
staff to be press secretary for his
final term um when the governor went to
Washington I joined New Hampshire
Bankers Association and that's when my
banking career began um and served as
president of that Organization for 20
years and um lobbied and represented the
industry before John and Leo Frasier and
Sheila franor and a whole bunch of other
chairperson
um that John will remember well uh for a
couple of decades um left did a term in
the state senate and at the end of that
term uh then Governor Hassen appointed
me as Bank commissioner and here I am um
and it's really a pleasure to still be
here uh I really enjoy public process
and working with legislators uh in the
state of New Hampshire the banking
Department um is uh fundament Mally
different from the Department you heard
this morning Department of Insurance um
from the get-go um commissioner
nicolopoulos told you this morning that
when it comes to Insurance all of the
regulation happens at the state level
there's nobody at the federal level that
does quite what they do banks are
entirely different we have a dual
banking system which means that the
state of New Hampshire and you as
legislators um Charter and guide
depository institutions like Bank Banks
and Credit Unions we have state
chartered Banks State chartered credit
unions and uh State chartered trust
companies and at the federal level there
is there are competing entities that are
federally chartered National Banks and
federal trust companies Federal Credit
Unions um the other piece of the puzzle
are the lenses and at this point in time
only States license non-bank
non-depository entities like Mortgage
Bankers and Brokers um debt adjusters
auto finance companies uh and the like
there is um a long history of regulatory
competition between the states and the
federal government when it comes to
banking related entities and right now
that competition is focused on the
licensing side of things where we have
both the office of the controller of the
currency and the um
cfpb um both making efforts to try to
become the First Federal agency to
license um non-bank providers of
products and services the banking
Department from a budget point of view
is broken into two accounting units um
one is for depository
institutions um CH excuse me chartered
institutions banks credit unions and
Trust companies and the other one for
lenses um the
agency itself does not reflect that
other than its budget which as you know
all of you can look up on the general
court website at this point in time and
see what our plans are um when it comes
to operations of the department we have
54 Personnel so we're a relatively small
agency um about eight of those positions
are funded but unfilled at this point in
time um and we are divided into five
divisions um there is a division for
bank and credit union supervision a
division for Trust Company supervision a
division for supervision of lenses again
those are um mortgage companies auto
finance companies small loan companies
uh debt adjusters Etc um there is a
division there's a legal division uh and
then we have an um Administration a
business Division and of all of those 50
ish employees more than half of them are
over the road staff they're Financial
examiners uh and they travel uh
generally haven't been doing that uh for
the past year obviously um they
generally would travel and go to the
facility where a bank a credit union a
trust company or a mortgage company um
or a small loan company is doing
business examine their books examine
their operations check their compliance
um and then file a report uh of that
institution we have state statutes um
that say that we have to visit and
examine and write a report on every
single one of the entities that we have
jurisdiction over once every 18 months
there is some um wiggle room in all of
that in that we also have the ability to
share exams with other states and share
exams that were done that are done by
the federal government when it comes to
banks credit unions um they we all have
a primary Federal regulator as well the
FDIC for banks the ncua for credit
unions and so we can alternate back and
forth and do one of their examinations
at the state level and accept for the
next 18 months examination one done by
our by our federal counterpart all of
this has really been um an interesting
challenge in the era of uh the Corona
virus um you're going to hear from our
Deputy Commissioner in a little bit and
she's going to tell you about some of
the things that we've been doing for a
while that left us interestingly
dramatically prepared seriously prepared
for when the pandemic hit it was nothing
that we really had anticipated but um
through the adoption of um of Technology
um and aggressive use uh or trying to
apply it to what we do at the bank
department for in all honesty to
generate um efficiency and effectiveness
of Regulation um we found that we were
very ready and some of that also had to
do with the fact um I hate to admit it
but we had an LBA audit and we learned a
lot of good stuff about ourselves um and
uh as a result we responded to the
recommendations that came in the LBA
audit um it was ultimately good for us
um and um I don't think they knew the
Corona virus was coming either but the
net result was we were very prepared uh
and uh Deputy Commissioner Emilia Galer
will tell you about that in a bit um we
also um have moved to a very strong um
Team centered Focus for operation of the
banking Department we have a management
team each of the five divisions I've
just mentioned to you is run by a
division director uh and uh that group
get gets together every other Monday
morning for often a couple of hours um
to discuss where we've been and where
we're going
uh and uh as a former legislator on
myself who was focused on fiscal and
finance committies um I recognize the
budget is probably one of the primary
public policy documents that is going to
go through the general court um in any
session uh and so um we re we um early
on uh when we got our request and
directed limits from the governor
recognized that this was going to be a
different type of year
that carried forward into our
discussions about how we would approach
the legislative session and recognize
that we thought that um and from a
little bit of intelligence we picked up
recognized that as your chairman has
recommended or as has told you um it's
probably not going to be an a lot an
awful lot of subcommittee work going on
and that if things are um controversial
if they're difficult if it's going to
take a lot of wrangling and and working
out there's a good chance that
legislation will be retained um that was
one of the assumptions that we made
going into this session and so while
Kiara dolino who is our general counsel
and will'll be the next to speak to you
um we'll talk to you about some
legislation she keeps a running list and
there are well over a hundred small
issues on that list what we try to do is
to group things together so that we can
bring you a bill that addresses a number
of different types of problems and
issues this year we decided we were
going to try to keep it as small as
possible we have two pieces of
legislation that we've requested
chairman hunt has graciously agreed to
be the sponsor of both of them we don't
believe there's much of anything uh that
is controversial at all in either of
those bills and that is by Design
because we recognize that you have a lot
on your plates we recognize that we're
in the age of the Corona virus and it's
going to be a different kind of session
um one thing we have always done before
we bring a piece of legislation forward
is draft it as well as we can and then
reached out to all of the stakeholders
anybody we think that might be
interested in this in the piece of
legislation and so we start our process
um with uh meetings um annually with all
of the various trade associations or
special interest groups that might have
um concern interest input give
Assistance or support for pieces of
legislation we meet with the credit
union Association we meet with the
bankers Association we meet with um the
uh Auto Dealers Association we meet with
the Mortgage Bankers and Brokers um the
small loan companies we call them all we
send them the draft language we ask for
their uh input their thoughts and often
they have comments or requests for
tweaks um we do our best to facilitate
everybody's concerns
uh before we even put the legislation
before the uh before the lawmakers um
that's happened again this year for both
of our pieces of of legislation and we
are hoping that the net result is that
um we have um made your life a little
bit easier during this difficult era
that we're in at this point in time uh
and that um those bills will move
through very quickly so this is a good
point right now for me to um tell you
that the next speaker will be Kiara
dolino I don't see her on the screen but
I I hope she's on the line or or with us
um and uh she will talk about the
legislative efforts that we've got
coming up before you this year she'll be
followed by Emelia garyi who is our
Deputy Commissioner and she'll tell you
about the sort of things that we're
looking at in the future so with that um
thank you chairman hunt and with your um
approval we will move to uh our general
counsel Kiara dolino yep word and upward
hi thank you very much uh Jerry yes my
name is Kiara doino I'm the general
counsel here at the banking Department
um I was previously with the insurance
department so um I'm very familiar with
the Commerce group and um very happy to
today hello how are you put your video
on oh you know I have a problem with my
internet connectivity and I am just keep
my fingers crossed I don't get kicked
off um the system so I unfortunately I
can't put them on my video I do have my
phone on in case I drop off I will pick
up my phone and and continue speaking
through my phone link so thank you for
your patience um so yes we do have two
bills um one is a fiscal what we call
our fiscal efficiency bill which is LSR
0545 um and this bill accomplishes
another number of important objectives
primarily aimed at reducing costs and
becoming more
efficient so uh the first change we're
requesting is for our licensed entities
uh which include retail sellers sales
finance companies that do auto loans um
small L small loan lenders debt
adjusters and money transmitters we're
seeking to have all those folks licensed
through the nmls system which is an
ronic licensing uh system uh this is a
much more efficient method for us and
for the lenes um currently we maintain
two separate licensing systems which is
obviously less efficient than using a
single system so we're seeking to have
everyone transition to this electronic
system um we did attempt um a first step
in making this happen last session in
hb1
1437 for our money transmitters but
unfortunately the bill got caught up
with all the covid related um
difficulties and was vetoed by the
governor um we also are seeking to have
a change in regard to our trust
companies uh last session there was a
bill put forward HB
1645 to allow us to conduct background
investigations for the new directors
appointed to trust companies so this
bill um um is again um that bill brought
forward a second time um and the fiscal
impact of this is that the cost for
conducting those investigations would be
borne by the trust companies
themselves in addition it allows the
direct excuse me the commissioner to
remove an officer or director if they
are shown to be um unqualified to
serve we were also seeking to have um
again in regard to last sessions hb6
1995 we're looking to have um the
ability to charge our chartered
institutions for their
applications um when those applications
come in and are very complex we're
seeking to have the ability to charge
more for those applications and also
increasing the charge for applications
filed for new institutions seeking to be
chartered um we're requesting
clarification uh for the right of the
department to charge companies that are
chartered by the department and then
either are dissolving or transitioning
to a federal Charter to pay their share
of the assessment if their dissolution
or their conversion to Federal Charter
happens sort of midye and we haven't yet
invoiced uh currently some of those
costs uh if we don't um make
arrangements with the company to pay
those charges those get shifted to um
all the institutions through the assess
so we're seeking to adjust that
payment uh we're also requesting that um
minimum interest rates for uh charges uh
for interest rates charged when are paid
when uh institutions have escrow
accounts for both tax and premium uh
interest uh pre insurance premium
payments uh that that interest rate be
set according to the Federal Open
markets committee federal funds interest
rate currently we calculate those rates
by asking our various institutions to
report their interest rates to us and we
we come up with that formula and we
report to them every year what they can
charge this way it would be become more
automatic and much more seamless um and
more
efficient and then finally uh also again
requested last session in hb1 1437 but
unfortunately did not pass uh did not
get uh put into law because it was
vetoed we're asking to have our consumer
complaints transmitted by email rather
than by certified mail currently we have
to send by certified mail that requires
copying costs and certified mailing
costs and it's slower we're seeking to
have a change so that we can send those
by
email so those are all the the changes
that we requesting that have a fiscal
impact and are part of um LSR 2021
questions okay great um the next next
bill is what we call our clarifications
bill which is LSR 2021 054 we do have a
question uh Chris Herbert hand up sorry
Chris you're still oh you took his hand
down and you're muted Chris so I can't
hear what you're telling okay I want to
come through John uh the chairman if I
may uh to help me out here
I'm I'm interested I know I thought that
the uh the trust companies you know to
be uh pay for our charges for checking
things out with them and that sort of
thing I thought that went through the
committee fairly easily and so I'm I'm
I'm wondering
why was this did we did all these things
just get bollocked up in well we had a
study committee and which Tina was on
and uh on the trust you know the trust
statue and this was the stuff that came
out of that that study committee but um
did remember what happened
why do Jerry do you remember why you got
vetoed if I if I might U Mr chairman
um the banking Department submissions to
that bill were not the reason for the
Governor's veto as a matter of fact um
it was part of the Christmas tree uh it
was a it was um a piece of legislation
that received no opposition in either
the house or Senate and moved through
very nicely because it had actually much
of it had had spun from a bill in
2019 and a study committee that
recommended all of these things happen
and so it moved forward pretty easily
last year um and was considered to be a
good piece of legislation people wanted
to pass but it was part of the Christmas
tree the governor vetoed for other
reasons not the banking Department um
requested legislation
okay CU I was a little surprised to hear
this uh because it sailed through
Commerce exactly and remember the last
session this the Senate you know started
combining bills and getting crazy with
putting bills together can never trust
those
Senators so anyway yes so it is the same
issue the same bill and and should
should be we shouldn't have any trouble
with this yes John um 210 545 has not
become a house bill yet it's still in
LSR
form I got it up on my other computer
all right stay tuned all right I guess
we're all set so thank you thank you K
so the the second bill um is our
clarifications bill I I only have the
LSR number I don't know if this became a
house bill yet but it's LSR 2021
0548 0548 hang on
keep going keep going okay I'll keep
going um so this bill is really um sort
of a technical bill it's making some
clarifications and again nothing that we
think is is
controversial um first we're trying to
clarify deadlines that apply when we
examine our Consumer Credit licensees
the current statutory language is
somewhat confusing um so we are looking
to clarify those deadlines and give a
little more time so that lenses can pull
together the records that they need for
us we're also um requesting a covid
related um
clarification we currently have a lot of
our mortgage loan Originators who are
teleworking from their homes under
current law it could require them to be
licensed in that quote Home State even
if they're not doing any business in
that state for example if they're living
in Massachusetts but working with only
New Hampshire consumers so we're seeking
some clarification to allow them to work
without having to get an unnecessary
license we're looking to clarify that
trust companies um Family Trust
companies can be examined more
frequently if necessary we believe we
have this Authority now but we're just
seeking to adjust the language and the
statute so that it's comparable to all
other exam Provisions for all other
examed
entities um we're clarifying that a
depository Bank can be a benefit
Corporation under
293c we've approved this already we
think this is already permissible but we
want to put something in the statutes
just to
clarify uh we're looking to clarify
requirements applicable to Credit Union
boards um having delegation to um boards
um and in credit unions and just
clarifying that they have to keep
minutes
Etc and finally we're looking uh to
adjust the restrictions that apply to
the commissioner Deputy Commissioner for
the types of personal loans they can
have again this was a bill that came
forward last session HB
1437 and as um commissioner little
mentioned it got caught up in the
Omnibus christm tree bills that were
veto by the governor so again we think
all these Provisions are very reasonable
and we don't expect any any
opposition great yes so representative
pusk has a question uh LSR 0540 is now
HP
312 beautiful number thank you you got
it that's part of my job as Vice chair
thank you okay now put your hand down
okay all
right uh is there any other questions
for all right thank you very much if not
um when Kiara is uh coming before you
with those two pieces of legislation if
you
have detailed questions that she can't
handle for you which she'll probably be
able to do she may show up with a
subject matter expert if it has to do
with banks and Credit Unions that will
be Chief Bank examiner Todd Wells if it
has to do with trust companies will be
director of trust supervision um Nancy
dangel renad and if it has to do with a
licensed entity a mortgage Banker or
auto finance or a small loan company
that will be our director of consumer
credit raayan shoy and then over all of
those people the secret sauce that makes
the banking Department work is Deputy
Commissioner Emelia galdieri and you may
also see her before your committee and
she's going to take the final portion of
our presentation this
afternoon okay sounds good I don't know
if I've ever been called The Secret
Sauce before so I'll take
it um good afternoon uh as commissioner
said my name is Amelia Galder and I am
the Deputy Commissioner at the new
Hampshire banking Department I've been
at the banking department for I think
nine years now um I started as a
enforcement attorney in the legal
Division and moved up to general counsel
um when I was General Counsel I was um
the legislative liaison um so I did
appear before house Commerce um quite
frequently at that time um and then I
moved on to become Deputy um so
commissioner little asked me to give you
an update about um where the banking
Department or what we've been up to and
um where the banking department is going
um so I'll go ahead and get to that um
basically if I could sum it all up in
one sentence it would be you know the
Department's been trying to leverage
technology um to create efficiencies and
um to continue to build on what we've
accomplished over the years um this
whole process began a few years ago um
really back in
2017 um at the department we began um a
big push to really document our policies
and procedures and get our our ducks in
a row so to speak um one of the first
policies and procedures that we
documented somewhat fortuitously it it
sounds like very strange when I'm
talking about this now but one of the
first policies that we did document was
a Tork policy um back in
2017 um so basically the department um
again fortuitously has been um is
familiar with uh teleworking we've been
telea workking on and off um with more
limitation obviously than we currently
are in the pandemic um but um currently
um you know that was a fortuitous
development um so then in
2019 um we instituted a new timekeeping
system um previous to our new
timekeeping system we had about three
systems that people had to input their
time into to track um for billing
purposes for um how we Bill our entities
for the examinations that we do to fund
the department and that was obviously
quite labor intensive um we combine
those all into one system um and um that
system has really created a lot of data
that we can use to um um further
understand our operations and um monitor
efficiencies and effectiveness of the
department um in 2020 we um undertook an
update to our strategic plan um and
again the our focus in updating the
Strategic plan was really to rely um on
evidence-based uh
practice um and use appropriate metrics
to measure our accomplishments um
related to the Strategic plan uh again
in 2020 um right as the pandemic hit um
in about about April we finalized our
continuity of operations plan um so that
was a about a two-year undertaking um
with a focus on again um somewhat
fortuitously um teleworking so our plan
all along in the event of a continuity
um situation was to have our folks Tork
so starting two years ago we began to
slowly Implement that so that
um the first week of the pandemic in
about mid-march when the governor gave
us the directive to all start
teleworking that was the week that the
last person at the department got a
laptop so that very week we all had
laptops we were all ready to go um we
were extraordinarily lucky um that that
happened so we've uh been comfortably uh
teleworking ever since um we were one of
the first agencies to do that I think
and um we're quite proud of that um
finally like the the most recent kind of
big accomplishment which actually
happened last week on January 4th was we
um update we created a a unified
database system for the department so um
prior to the start of this new database
we had about 10
um for the computer nerds out there
access 1997 databases um that we were
operating about two years ago um
starting two years ago we started this
process of updating them and
consolidating them so um as of January
4th we had taken about six of those 10
and have Consolidated them into one
database with modern technology um that
complements our timekeeping system so it
all sort of works together um and as you
might imagine that's generated um of
efficiency um obviously we're still kind
of working through the hiccups of having
a new database as of January 4th um but
overall um it's all going very well and
I apologize if you just heard that my
dog walked down the stairs and barked I
apologize always happens um so um that's
kind of what we've been up to um and um
where we're going now is um we are
obviously um have been pretty
extensively leveraging telea workk
during the pandemic
and um in monitoring different metrics
um we found that that's create um
created a great deal of efficiency at
the department um so for example we just
calculated our 2020 assessment which is
um to the extent that we don't recoup
our expenses um we Bill our chartered
entities for cost associated with their
regulation um and that uh the 2020
assessment actually went down by 30% as
compared to last year um and we were
able to pinpoint um what that was due to
um and we found that we were able while
telea workking we were able to do more
examinations so that increased Revenue
um while at the same time we had less um
expenses because we weren't traveling as
much um and that generated a lot of cost
efficiency um traveling less is been
something that we've kind of been
exploring because we want to be you know
we're very mindful of any burdens that
we place on our regulated entities so it
was actually something we were kind of
exploring before the pandemic but it's
been obviously greatly magnified by the
fact that none of us can travel anywhere
um we've also been exploring um reducing
office space to create some budgetary
efficiency um we found that um some of
our staff can be assigned to full-time
Tork and we can track the metrics and
see that they're getting their jobs done
so um we are beginning to explore red
producing our office footprint obviously
we do need some office because we have a
consumer um facing component of our
operations and also we have some um
business office staff who um need to be
in the office um so we're exploring that
um another important thing to note is
that um all all the divisions at the
banking Department are currently are in
about 2020 um as of are now um
nationally accredited by the um
Conference of State Bank supervisors
which is our um National Trade
Organization for um Bank
Regulators um that's something uh we
worked really hard at um specifically we
were working hard to adopt make sure we
adopted all the best practices um for
managing the entities that we uh
regulate so that's something we're
pretty proud of and we we're looking to
maintain that accreditation as we move
forward um and finally one last thing
I'll mention is that we're continuing to
develop and monitor um metric about our
operations um that has been um with all
these datadriven kind of changes we've
been making at the department with
databases and timekeeping um that's
really created a really data Rich
environment that's allowed us to track
kind of our efficiencies um so that's
something we're going to keep keep
moving forward on uh and I'm happy to uh
answer any
questions that's it Mr chairman well I'm
very impressed with this efficiency the
model of efficiency that's great
um myself that if I don't have to drive
to conquer that that saves an hour to an
hour home an hour back so it definitely
drive time is definitely a a big problem
when you have to farflung parts of the
state so that's great well as Emilia has
said we had been spent we'd spent the
past couple two three years planning to
drive efficiency through technology and
data accumulation and it was I guess you
would say a sad occurrence that we land
ready just in time for the Corona virus
to hit and just stepped right off the
traditional way of operating into
teleworking and virtual agency very
smoothly very quickly on day one that's
awesome okay any questions uh
representative pusk has a question yes
John thank you uh it's slightly
technical um for
Amilia how difficult was it to first of
all were these all access databases and
how difficult was it to take this
mass
and put them all
together uh very I would just to me
who's not um a techie person but I do
work with the techie Folks at our office
quite a bit um it it was very
complicated because we sort of had all
these cobbled together systems and the
best way I can describe it as you know
if you were to start out and build a
house from scratch you would start with
the foundation and then you build the
frames and you plan where you're going
to put a door and a window and you know
you build it nice and neat and square um
but what happened over the years because
these were all n they were access 97
databases that had just been made ad hoc
by basically folks in our office even
before we had it staff you know um it
was quite a mess on the back so what
we've done um not to get too technical
is we took we um hired a database um I'm
not sure the best way to describe her I
call her my database magician so we'll
call her my database magician um and and
she took all of our data and organized
it um into SQL uh Ms SQL um backend and
then um we put a modern access front end
on the database so that we can access
that data but now all the data is nicely
organized um so you're not like uh you
know going into a window to get to the
basement to you know it's all
square that's how I think of it anyway
perfect so if if I could just add
something ailia um
at in 2016 we had a a very rigidly
siloed
Department um with not much
communication among the silos uh and one
of the first things to do was to flatten
that and open up the doors between the
the agencies the divisions of the agency
and that's where the management team
concept came in and has worked really
well that team does everything from
designing the budget as a group to
talking about technology to doing the
strategic planning to continuity
everybody works together on that and
when we realized that we wanted to
become a modern virtual agency we needed
technology to do it we looked around and
said so how do we do it so everybody
talks together so you know this division
over here had two of their own databases
and this division over here had two
databases and it took a lot of
cooperation between the divisions to get
that done we had one part-time doit
embedded person in the agency at that
point in time and so that has to be
addressed through the budget which is a
long slow process but if you look far
enough down the the road you can see
where the choice point is going to come
the fork in the road and you make
decisions where you're going to be able
to spend your limited amount of
resources for the year and we made
decisions that we wanted two full-time
um tech people in the bank department so
we could move the rest of the agenda
forward and so the database magician um
that um Amelia has mentioned um came on
board as did another doit um Tech more
techy kind of person um to help us get
to where we needed to be for electronic
communication and um those are think the
big things was that we embraced
technology and then made strategic
decisions to support
it cool good any other questions oh yes
Don I was writing down the bill numbers
can I got the HB 312 I was listening and
I didn't get a chance to write it down
my pen died I had to find a new pen
can you give me the other bill number
just I just want to I like looking them
over the other one is still in LSR uh so
you won't be able to get to the language
quite yet that's right so yeah I would
you just look at at the advanced
business or look at the committee and as
the bills are um because I I I just
talked to Paul Smith and he said uh
we're now at 42 bills
and that he's knew he had he had he's
still waiting another 40 bills because
of fiscal notes so I assume you're not
holding up any bills with fiscal notes
but um but uh so otherwise he did say
that uh they will be making a decision
today um and to whether I can start
scheduling bills for next week um and
the expectation is that um they really
want to make sure all the bills are
together so we're scheduling we're
bundling things together so once I know
when I have all the banking bills
together then then we will be scheduling
a banking day and and get through all
those those different bills
representative if you want the LSR
0545 okay and uh so I guess that's about
it everybody any more questions and um
in the banking Department we've had uh
you know over the years we've uh um
we've done a lot of recodification and
reorganizing the statutes and uh got
them all straightened out and for
anybody who is interested they do not do
Bitcoin Bitcoin is been been pulled out
and is done under the consumer
protection Division and and I and I
guess uh we we will have consumer
protection tomorrow but um uh you if you
ever when we talk about the most
important 358a RSA um there are some
little language little things Stucky
there on the back that are banking
related uh and uh so that over the years
that has been an issue but um I think we
have good firewalls and we have great
protections and we have great statutes
and and awesome people and joining our
banking department and and uh so we're I
think we're in good
hands having said that I guess we're all
set I guess I want to just let know I
don't see how many well still another 13
attendees so any of you attendees who
are listening in if you're a lobbyist
your opportunity to uh introduce
yourself will'll be tomorrow at
11:15 and with that I guess we're we're
all finished yes Pam I just want to make
one um final note I sent you only the
your personal invitation to this meeting
so far because I just wanted to you know
give you only one option and not confuse
anybody with two uh so as soon as we um
you know leave this meeting I will send
you your personal invitation to
tomorrow's meeting if you don't get it
for some reason which I think has been
happening a little bit I don't and on
the first pass and please let me know my
address is pam. smarlin
ledge. state. n. us and um try to sort
it out but I I have um um changed
addresses you know as as requested and
so hopefully that that will help
straighten things out and we'll see
which one I get it at yeah I send them
to both of yours because
it's but I I'd like to you know find the
right email address that you look you
know that you will um use and and you
know have a a a good list going forward
thanks okay yes John Pam can you carbon
copy can you CC my personal address
also or do you have to use just one
address I just I have to use just one
address it's it's a it's a field in Zoom
I'm not sending you emails from my email
uh account all right because I I I told
you what I have to do to get this thing
to
happen I got to transfer one mail to
another mail to to Comcast so I can
bring it up on my laptop because my my
desktop does not have a camera and a
microphone so it's a it's a little
process right well computers are
certainly a process but then again I can
sit here and look at two computers there
you go there's a benefit there is a
benefit that's how I called up made sure
I just looked up yeah we got 42 bills
now yeah well I hopefully we won't have
too many issues with with all everybody
else um my my particular problem was
that my my email address was Prodigy
which is some of you might know is older
than AOL it's the oldest oldest email
address out there and um and there was a
conquered uh cable company was decided
that Prodigy was anybody who has Prodigy
was was fraudulent and they were
bouncing all my emails from The Liquor
Commission
and so so I I do have a Gmail account
because I have a Samsung phone so but I
I don't want to give out that too much
because it's I'm trying to keep
everything on my Prodigy account so but
if you ever have problems um that some
you know they can can be your related to
your email unfortunately your your
address but all right so this is great
uh we and we'll take this up again at
nine o'clock tomorrow morning and thank
you all and we'll talk to you tomorrow
representative bolo has her her physical
hand up oh represent I thought I thought
she was waving
you want to say something Jane yes I do
um I'm sorry I didn't attend uh this
morning but I'm glad I'm here this
afternoon um I know that you're at the
state house because the background is
very familiar that's a trick oh is it is
it there goes my hmer
what so is anyone at the state house
right now I mean working any
committees committees no no no I got an
Ann did this picture for me so oh great
and another question I know we have a
lot of bills so um we'll probably go
every day once we get going well you
know historically you know we we would
be Tuesday Wednesday Thursdays okay the
the issue now is that uh the state we
only have five count on five of licenses
so you know like the old days where
every committee could be busy busy busy
um only you know only going to be five
who be going at a given time so we are
going to be told what days we can do our
do our hearings and stuff like that um I
I told them I'm because I'm on the
county executive committee so in chesher
so I told them Monday mornings is not
going to work for me so hopefully
they'll remember that um but so in terms
of what days it will be or times it's I
I can't it's that that's supposed to be
like I said that's supposed to be
figured out right now um when they're
going to do that and it's somewhat
determined by how many bills each
committee has and they absolutely want
us to do our grouping you know group
bills together in terms of the hearings
and that even a radical idea of
overlapping which Commerce uh we did we
dabbled a little bit of that last year
with with straws and and plastic bags
overlapping and it and it was really
necessary because most of the people
were coming in to testify from both
bills so it made it did make things EAS
easier doing that but it also made
things a little confusing in terms of
you know in terms of the process and how
I build here so we'll see me I I
generally generally like to do each bill
at a time but if some are so over you
know so obviously going to you be that
you know I might I might join him
together but um I don't know we'll see
we'll see how it goes yeah and and um I
wasn't here this morning so um I I just
wanted to um give you a little bit more
background to let you know that I I
served on environment and agriculture
Municipal and County government and uh
resources Recreation and development and
I'm currently on a commission for
offshore um wind and Port development
and I'm also a Manchester School Board
member which school board member which
keeps me you weren't you on the city
council too or at some point I was uh no
I was not an alderman but I was on the
Conservation Commission for 20 years
because your your father was the mayor
right was my father was the mayor and he
was a state legislator in the 70s yeah
yeah thanks well welcome to Commerce
you're you're on the best committee now
yeah thank
you all right great so we'll see you all
uh tomorrow thank you much thank you for
the banking
so I think that went good Pam what do
you think you I think it went really
well um you know there were a couple of
members three members came in through
the
attendees again right that first thing
in the morning yeah yeah and so that's
just something to keep an eye out I
representative Ammon was one of them and
he emailed me about you know clerk
responsibility so I wrote back and said
you know I'd be happy to talk to him
about clerk responsibilities though I
knew that Paul Smith would be doing a a
Clerk's meeting that's or
I don't know I you know he usually does
a Clerk's um meeting sort of training
session but then then I asked him why he
came in as an attendee and he said he
didn't get the invitation though I sent
it to his the address he asked for you
know his Gmail address and I really um
am mystified by it because some people
is Gmail a problem then maybe it was
wasn't it my Gmail that I didn't get
because you initially sent it to me
that's right Gmail account it might be
Gmail's the problem maybe but some
that's that's a theory to work on
because some people you know said they
didn't get it and all I did was resend I
didn't change anything I just hit the
resend button and it did work didn't
work so it's almost like it it needed
two tries to it burped it burped at a
moment when it well that's exactly what
I said I think I think uh Zoom hiccups
sometimes but you know it's not a good
feeling as long as it only hiccups once
in the very beginning like gu
establishing its root I don't know you
know I'm just not a tech person
so I do my best um but I do hope we we
we establish you know set um you know
links so that you just save your
Commerce link and you just go in there
it's a recurring meeting and and it's
like you know just getting yourself to
the meeting because it's amazingly time
consuming to yeah pain in the budget I
have to resend it each time and and well
I resend and then people still don't get
back so I have to call them I've been I
have to call like I had to call most of
Commerce and I'm calling most of Edna
and it it's like please look at your
legislative email and you know they get
so much email it's confusing and and
yeah yeah and this is this is the time
of year where it starts picking up again
and and um yeah I understand you know
missing emails I believe me I've been
there myself but but there's no way to
know that they you know we need to know
people got it so they can come to the
meeting right what was crazy for me
because when you sent the notice saying